Любов Дичук, мешканка села Павлівка на Вінниччині, не стримує обурення.
Вже минув рік, як її будинок було пошкоджено вибуховою хвилею
від розриву снарядів на військових складах. А дім досі без ремонту.
Стільки грошей напозичались, зима йде.
У мене 1500 пенсія, а в дітей два школярі.  А зараз знаєте, які зарплати? Що й казати.
Зроблений нашвидкуруч державними будівельниками дах, тепер доводиться переробляти.
12 тисяч гривень на шифер - ось практично і вся компенсація, яку отримала жінка.
На решту - грошей не дають.
Це "не положено". Дивіться, які щілини.
Це "не положено". Тут був гарнітур, все порозкидало, побило всю плитку і це "не положено".
Односельчанці Інні пощастило ще менше. Тріщини на стінах, на стелях.
Покриття може обвалитись будь-якої миті.
Втім експертна комісія цього не зауважила і хату аварійною не визнала.
Тож, поки Інна з двома дІтьми знімає інше помешкання, в її будинку поселились безхатченки.
Тут хтось сидить. Подивіться, ось пляшки стоять, цигарки. Подивіться,скільки тампляшок.
Хліб хтось не доїв.
Павлівка знаходиться за два кілометри від військових складів з боєприпасами.
Тож, це село постраждало найбільше.
В яку хату не постукай - скрізь знайдеться, що показати. Потріскані стіни, розбитий дах.
Сільський голова Віктор Кособуцький на запитання, як пройшов рік, не без іронії відповідає:
Весело.
Зараз його телефон обривають колеги з Ічні.
Запитають, що і як робити, аби якнайшвидше отримати грошову компенсацію.
Він лише співчуває.
Рік тому Вінниччині, як нині й ІчнІ, уряд виділив 100 мільйонів гривень.
Утім вже наприкінці 2017 року 60 мільйонів довелося повернути.
Гроші, каже, не опрацювали через складну і занадто бюрократичну постанову Кабміну.
Кошториси роблять певні підрядні організації, вони приватні, їх не так багато насамперед.
Кошторис складається на все господарство, після того йде на погодження у три міністерства в Києві.
На якомусь з етапів суму відшкодувань можуть скоротити у три, а той чотири рази.
Втім, навіть занижену компенсацію готівкою не віддають.
Людям пропонують послуги чи будматеріали. Часто неякісні та дешеві.
Приміром, у будинку родини Кухт ремонтник пошкодив електропроводку і не полагодив її.
А в коридорі, замість енергозберігаючого вікна, яке родина поставила напередодні вибухів,
сільська влада встановила гірше.
Відсутність вибору - обурює селян.
Чи ми дорожче щось наймемо, чи дешевше, але це наше відшкодування.
Ну як так гроші виділили і не дали людям?
Найдивніше, що побачити кошторис з остаточними сумами відшкодувань люди не можуть.
Хоча селищний голова запевняє: за зверненням документ має надати районна рада.
Антолій писав не одне таке звернення, втім кошторис на свій будинок,
каже, отримав неофіційно, з дружньої допомоги одного з чиновників.
Дивується, адже в документі зазначено послуги, які не проводились.
Перевезення сміття на 12 кілометрів, подоконики пластікові,
я їх в очі не бачив, а тут написано, що їх поставили.
Селяни не доотримують грошей не лише через бюрократію,
але й через зловживання місцевої влади, припускає сільська активістка Юлія Гурман,
будинок якої теж постраждав.
За два тижні до проведення тендеру по вікнах була створена фірма, якраз навпроти частини.
І та фірма якраз належить одному з родичів наших місцевих чиновників.
Разом з іншими небайдужими вона хоче розслідувати можливі випадки порушень.
Окрім того вважає, що до відшкодування матеріальної шкоди влада має включати і моральну.
Адже й досі місцеві жителі продовжують жити у страху
та, як і їхні пошкодженні будинки, здригаються від щоденних вибухів.
Які від березня, планово, тривають на військових складах.